bisschen mehr aber
wenn ich was Grünes an hätte dann wäre
ich so ein lebendiger Weihnachtsbaum
damit ich so machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt die Weihnachtstorte
2022 ja heute packen wir eine
Weihnachtstorte deswegen sind wir schon
richtig in Weihnachtsstimmung muss ich
sagen und ich habe die letzten Jahre
schon einige weihnachtstorten gebacken
mit Figuren drauf ohne Fondant mit
Fondant einen 3D Weihnachtsshow es gibt
wirklich schon alles Mögliche eine
Geschenkbox gibt's auch noch habe ich
mir überlegt was könnte ich denn jetzt
noch zubereiten es gibt heute ich meine
man kann ja nicht immer den perfekten
Mann haben ja ich habe den perfekten
Murat an meiner Seite aber wenn ihr den
perfekten Murat an eurer Seite habt dann
solltet ihr euch jetzt vielleicht den
perfekten Mann Backen einen Ginger bread
man also einen Lebkuchenmännchen in 3D
schön groß können natürlich auch als
Weibchen zubereiten und dazu zeige ich
euch jetzt erstmal die Zutaten
für den Teig verwende ich 250 Gramm
Butter 100 g Honig 200 g
Zartbitterschokolade 3 Eier eine Prise
Salz 200g Zucker etwas Vanilleextrakt
200g Haselnüsse die werden gleich noch
gemahlen 100 g gehackte und geröstete
Haselnüsse 100 g Cranberries 200 g Milch
einen Esslöffel Lebkuchengewürz und 400
g Mehl plus Backpulver oder ihr nehmt
einfach das backmehl da ist nämlich
Backpulver schon mit dabei es sieht nach
ziemlich vielen Zutaten aus sind auch
viele aber das wird ein richtig leckerer
Kuchen also ich werde zuerst einmal die
Butter in den Topf geben und mit dem
Honig schmelzen
das macht ihr einfach bei mittelhoher
Hitze die buttersäule jetzt nicht kochen
auf Stufe 4
und sobald der Honig hier dabei ist und
sich auch so ein bisschen mit der Butter
vermengt hat schaltet ihr den Herd aus
gebt die Schokolade dazu und lasst sie
einfach in der Restwärme schmelzen
[Musik]
und dann kann ich in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Haselnüsse fein reiben
[Musik]
dann kann ich jetzt in der Zwischenzeit
die Eier in die Rührschüssel geben Salz
und Zucker dazu
und etwas Vanilleextrakt
und dann die Zutaten für etwa 5 Minuten
cremig verrühren
[Musik]
dann geht es jetzt weiter jetzt können
die flüssigen Zutaten hier mit in die
Rührschüssel und damit die
Schokoladenmasse jetzt nicht so heiß ist
gebe ich einfach die Milch noch mit dazu
dann kühlt das Ganze gut ab
dann kann ich es hier mit dazu gießen
und das ist kurz einrühren aber bei
niedriger Stufe
und die trockenen Zutaten dann ebenfalls
kurz einrühren
auch die Cranberries
und die Haselnüsse und die nur leicht
unterrühren
dann habe ich jetzt hier ein Lochblech
mit einer Dauerbackfolie da kommt jetzt
der Backrahmen drauf der ist ja quasi
ein Backblech Ersatz und zwar ist es
dann später einfach ein perfekter Kasten
also ein perfekter rechtwinkliger Kasten
und die Backzeit ist etwas kürzer als
bei herkömmlichen Backblechen die ist
ebenso im Ofen gibt und hat eben diese
schönen rechtwinkligen Ecken und einen
geraden Boden den Ofen habe ich jetzt
auch bereits vorgeheizt auf 170 Grad
ober Unterhitze und jetzt fühle ich den
Teig hier in die Backform ein Streichen
glatt und dann wird er im Ofen gebacken
für etwa 30 bis 35 Minuten
und währenddessen mache ich schon mal
die Ganache
[Musik]
jetzt kümmere ich mich hier schon mal um
die Schokoladencreme es gibt endlich mal
wieder eine Vollmilch Garage das heißt
das eine Creme aus Sahne und
Vollmilchschokolade die Sahne kommt
jetzt hier direkt in den Topf und wird
aufgekocht das könnte jetzt auf dem Herd
machen oder auch gerne in der Kennwort
ich mache das jetzt hier direkt in der
Kennwort da muss ich nämlich nicht
selber rühren das ist ganz praktisch das
heißt hier kurz aufkochen lassen und
wenn ihr wollt dann könnt ihr hier auch
gerne noch etwas Lebkuchengewürz
dazugeben oder ihr lasst es weg wenn ihr
sagt euch reicht der Geschmack dann
schon aus also hier einmal kurz
aufkochen
dabei muss jetzt auch nicht gerührt
werden ich mache jetzt aber einfach bis
etwa 96 Grad ich mache 90 Grad und da
muss ich dann nämlich nicht aufpassen
dass da nichts überkocht und das
Lebkuchengewürz kann ich aber schon mal
dazu geben
dann wird das schon mal schön warm und
das Aroma entfaltet sich gut
jetzt ist die Sahne warm und jetzt kann
ich hier die Kuvertüre direkt dazugeben
Hitze ausstellen und dann einfach
verrühren bis sie eben schön geschmolzen
ist
[Musik]
ja hast du Durst
ja ja komm
komm hier
dann komm gebe ich dir halt Wasser
ach da ist ein kleiner Snack da ist eine
Spinne
an dir
[Musik]
die trinken halt nur frisches Wasser aus
dem Wasserhahn aber immer vom Badezimmer
wenn man versuchen Sie es in der Küche
aber das dürfen sie nicht
umfüllen abdecken bei Raumtemperatur
stehen lassen und dann ist der Kuchen
auch schon kalt und kann direkt gefüllt
werden ich glaube ich zeichne jetzt
erstmal vor wie mein Lebkuchenmännchen
aussehen soll
für meine Lebkuchenmann habe ich mir
gedacht mache ich eine süße Fliege eine
Weihnachtsmütze und zusätzlich dann noch
Knöpfe und Ärmel aus Fondant die aber
wie Zuckerguss Aussehen erstmal
schneiden wir aber jetzt die Böden
zurecht
jetzt ist der Kuchen schön ausgekühlt
ich hatte ihn auch kurz im Kühlschrank
kann ihn jetzt hier erstmal rauslösen
dann ziehe ich die Backfolie drunter weg
dann am besten durchsägen einmal mit der
tortensäge oder einem Tortenmesser es
kann ein bisschen schwierig sein wegen
den Cranberries im Teig es schmeckt da
immer so ein bisschen Widerstand
und jetzt mache ich es erstmal so dass
ich das Lebkuchenmännchen ausschneide
und den Rest drumrum benutze ich dann
nämlich um ihn schön auszufüllen
[Musik]
also mit den Cranberries muss ich sagen
habe ich mir jetzt keinen Gefallen getan
denn sie zerstören den Boden ein
bisschen das ist einer der man
eigentlich über Nacht am besten einpackt
und kühllagert dann zieht ein bisschen
durch und dann ist er echt noch mal ein
bisschen besser und bröselt nicht so
sehr aber ich wollte unbedingt heute
backen aber wie gesagt falls ihr euch
ein bisschen einfacher machen wollt
macht den Manuel Kuchen da könnt ihr
nämlich das Rezept auch einfach auf dem
Blech umrechnen weil ich habe das Rezept
als 20 cm Ring angegeben und dann können
wir das auch zubereiten gut dann kommt
da erstmal eine Schicht fruchtmarmelade
drauf also so eine Fruchtaufstrich könnt
ihr da gerne nehmen das schmeckt es
hoffentlich wie
diese Lebkuchen mit marmeladenfüllung
[Musik]
und da kommt jetzt eine Schicht Ganache
drauf
[Musik]
falls ihr die Torte jetzt ein bisschen
höher gestalten wollt so wie jetzt ich
dann legt ihr am besten diese restlichen
kuchenteile zusammen
und schneidet noch mal ein
Lebkuchenmännchen aus die puzzelt ihr
dann dazwischen und das nehme ich jetzt
nicht als obere Schicht sondern als
Zwischenschicht und legt dann dieses
zweite oben drauf dann habe ich eine
schöne hohe Torte
sieht doch schon mal ganz gut aus
sieht gerade aus bisschen wie so ein
Tatort aber sieht gut aus bitte zeigen
ich packe da jetzt einen eckigen
Backrahmen außen herum kann das ganze
mit dem tortenretter abdecken da kommt
es in den Kühlschrank die Reste hier
hebe ich aber noch auf denn vielleicht
brauche ich den noch
na darf die Torte jetzt erstmal
durchkühlen die ganach wird abgedeckt
und dann geht's gleich weiter
der Kuchen ist jetzt schön durchgekühlt
und ich möchte dass da jetzt ein
bisschen abgerundet ist dass mein
Lebkuchen Menschen ein bisschen
realistischer aussieht oder einfach
dreidimensionaler und es ist auch
einfacher nicht so eine harte Kante zu
haben beim Überziehen später mit Fondant
sondern so ein bisschen abgerundeter
deswegen schneide ich jetzt hier einfach
immer die Kanten weg und nehme dann die
restliche Ganache immer wieder zum
einstreichen und dann könnt ihr noch
gerne die restlichen Kuchenstücke nehmen
und hier auch so kleine Rundungen drauf
zaubern ja also alles was jetzt hier
drei dimensional plastisch passiert ist
mit Ganache und mit kuchenresten mit
einem Messer und einer Palette
[Musik]
beim Bestreichen achte ich jetzt immer
drauf dass ich den Gingerbread man auch
zwischendurch mal kühl stelle dann zieht
die Ganache nämlich schön fest an und
dann könnt ihr quasi mit einer sauberen
ganachschicht einmal schön abschließen
[Musik]
und dann schneide ich hier unten das
ganze so ein bisschen rundlicher weg
damit es einfach nicht so gerade endet
sondern eben eine schöne Rundung hat
dann sieht so drei wird dimensionaler
aus und ihr könnt hier so eine Teigkarte
nehmen oder ein Stück Kunststoff zum
Beispiel von einem Joghurtbecher und
könnt dann hier immer damit so entlang
fahren denn damit kann man so die die
Rundungen einfach besser nachfragen
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt mein Lebkuchenmann aus
richtig schön ich habe den am Ende
einfach so mit den Fingern bisschen
glatt gestrichen der ist jetzt hier und
ich habe die Zwischenzeit auch genutzt
um Fondant weich zu kneten ich habe
jetzt hier einfach so einen
schokoladenfarbigen Fondant ich überlege
dann immer wie ist die Form und dann
einfach ein bisschen größer
muss jetzt kein Kreis sein sondern eher
ein Rechteck
[Musik]
ich guck schon mal aufs passt
minimal
minimal größer werden
[Musik]
damit der Fondant haftet kommt da jetzt
eine dünne Schicht backtrennspray drauf
und dann legt ihr die Fondant Decke
jetzt drüber
nichts schön von der Mitte heraus
arbeiten
gehen wir erstmal die Mitte glatt
streichen
dann nach unten und immer so ein
bisschen stretchen und nach unten hin
ausdehnen
dann kriegt man auch schön alle Falten
weg und ich drücke dann hier unten das
Ganze immer gern so an den Kuchen dran
seht ihr schon dann verschwindet da
diese Luftlinie oder diese luftlücke und
dann kann ich nämlich da drumherum
wegschneiden ohne dass ich quasi zu viel
wegschneidet großzügiger wegschneiden
und dann noch mal im Detail dran gehen
[Musik]
so gefällt er mir schon richtig gut ich
packe den jetzt einfach in den
Kühlschrank sobald Fondant auf der Torte
ist muss die Torte und soll die Torte
auch nicht mehr abgedeckt werden da sie
ansonsten Feuchtigkeit sieht das heißt
so kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank über
Nacht heute wird er jetzt nicht mehr
weiter dekoriert sondern morgen
jetzt schon süß aus
[Musik]
neuer Tag neues Glück jetzt wird der
Lebkuchen
Gingerbread men fertiggestellt ich habe
jetzt hier aus kuchenresten und Ganache
die kann ich jetzt nämlich miteinander
verrühren falls die Ganache zu fest ist
erhitzt er sie einfach noch mal und
verknetet die Zutaten so dass eine
klebrige Masse entsteht und dann könnt
ihr wie so eine Art Weihnachtsmütze
Formen falls ihr keine Kuchenreste habt
könnt ihr auch gerne Rice crispy Masse
verwenden da gibt's auch ein Rezept
schon auf meinem Kanal und formt das
einfach richtig schön stell's in den
Kühlschrank und später kann ich das dann
benutzen und mit Fondant überziehen aber
jetzt geht's erstmal mit dem Ginger
brennt man weiter ich brauche jetzt rote
weiße und schwarze von Sandmasse die ich
jetzt weich Knete damit ich gleich Deko
machen kann
der ist jetzt schön durchgekühlt die
Fondant Masse ist jetzt auch schön fest
und jetzt kann ich das ganze schon mal
auf die Servierplatte packen wo es quasi
auch
serviert wird
sehe ich den ein bisschen runter
damit Platz ist für die Weihnachtsmütze
dann habe ich hier meine Vorlage zum
einen brauche ich eine Schleife ich
brauche Druckknöpfe und natürlich das
Gesicht für die Wangen habe ich jetzt
hier etwas rot und weiß verknetet das
Rolle ich jetzt dünn aus mit etwas
Becker Stärke für die Wange nehme ich
zum Ausstechen einfach eine Spritztülle
hier diese Rückseite und kann jetzt hier
zwei Kreise ausstechen und alle
Dekoelemente lege ich jetzt hier erstmal
zur Seite die Augen mache ich schwarz
die Rolle ich aber ein bisschen dicker
aus
aus weißem Fondant oder aus weißer
Blütenpaste könnt ihr dann die ganzen
Linien hier Formen das heißt alles schön
gleichmäßig ausrollen
[Musik]
hier noch zwei gleichmäßig dünne Stücke
für die Augenbrauen
für die Knöpfe habe ich jetzt hier
einfach eine Silikonform verwendet da
könnt ihr zum Beispiel Blütenpaste
zusammenrollen schön reindrücken und
trocknen lassen ich bin jetzt die
Blütenpaste immer gern mit bisschen
bäckerstärke und dann setze das rein
drückt schön an und wenn ihr seht dass
hier beim ersten das ein bisschen zu
viel ist schneidet ihr den Rest einfach
runter und dann passt sich das schön an
ich streichel es dann quasi immer so ein
bisschen in die Form und fertig und
anschließend könnt ihr die Knöpfe ganz
einfach hier raus lösen
die Schleife wird jetzt etwas
breitdimensionaler gestaltet dafür nehme
ich jetzt etwas grün grün und Fondant da
kommt zehn Prüfer rein das ist Cellulose
und sorgt dafür dass die Schleife dann
auch aushärten kann das wird jetzt hier
reingeknetet und dann gebe ich euch eine
schnelle kurze Anleitung für eine
Fondant Schleife die ihr auch gerne zum
Beispiel beim Marzipan anwenden könnt
man merkt auch direkt das Thema etwas
fester wird und dann lässt sie sich eben
super verarbeiten
jetzt kommt ihr hier einen langen Strang
dann ein bisschen flachräumen
vorher hatte ich immer diesen Kunststoff
aus der rutscht immer aus der Hand und
man muss mit beiden Händen arbeiten und
hier kann man schön mit einer Hand
ausrollen und mit einer Hand weiter
modellieren perfekt
dann hier etwas schneiden also schön
parallel rechts und links auch gerade
wegschneiden
dann formt ihr euch als etwas
Küchenpapier einfach eine Rolle und
halbiert sie und jetzt formt ihr hier
quasi die Schleife nach innen
und hier auch von außen nach innen da
kommt jetzt Kleber rein etwas essbarer
Kleber also einmal hier in die Mitte
dann hier an den Seiten
und damit das Ganze dreidimensional
bleibt kommt hier die Rolle rein
macht dazwischen klemmen
und die Schleife oben verschließen
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr hier noch
mit einem Modellierwerkzeug einfach so
eine kleine Mulde reindrücken
[Musik]
und jetzt quält quasi nur noch hier
dieses Zwischenstück also noch mal ein
bisschen Grün ausrollen diesmal etwas
dicker
[Musik]
hier auch hier so eine Mulde rein und es
legt jetzt quasi einmal oben drüber und
verschließt unten
[Musik]
das sieht so süß aus das lasse ich jetzt
hier an der Seite einfach trocknen was
fehlt mir noch eigentlich nichts ich
kann so lange die Schleife antrocknet
hier das Gesicht und die ganzen Linien
einfach mit essbarem Kleber schon mal
ankleben
[Musik]
hier lege ich einfach die Linie entlang
schneidet dann weg und klebst sie dann
an
[Musik]
dann könnt ihr hier sobald die Schleife
angetrocknet ist einfach das Papier
wegnehmen
und die Schleife mit ankleben
[Musik]
wähle den Lebkuchenmann jetzt noch ein
bisschen dreidimensionaler gestalten
wollt und so ein bisschen Tiefe und
Schatten geben wollt dann nehmt ihr am
besten Pulverfarben braun und schwarz
mischt das ganze und nehmt einen
trockenen fluffigen Pinsel also wie so
ein Lidschattenpinsel mit dem man so ein
bisschen den Lidschatten
verblendet sonnenblending Pinsel und
dann könnt ihr nämlich damit so ein
bisschen die Schatten reinzeichnen also
so rein schattieren
sagen man wenn man den perfekten Partner
noch nicht gefunden hat dann packt man
ihn einfach
ja
ich finde das ist auch so das sind so
die dann sieht es richtig aus wie
Lebkuchen weil das sind so diese Stellen
im Backofen die so ein bisschen dunkel
werden und glänzen und dann ist richtig
[Musik]
süß das sieht so schon perfekt aus aber
der kriegt jetzt noch eine
Weihnachtsmütze
da hole ich doch mal meinen Kuchenstück
raus
ich weiß noch nicht ob mehr die
Weihnachtsmütze gefallen wird ich legte
deshalb noch nicht da drauf sondern
probiere es erstmal hier
ich habe jetzt hier die
Schokolade da kommt jetzt roter Fondant
drauf also der Rest Kuchen sozusagen war
das ja hier
dann roter Fondant
und am besten
Mantel ich ziehe komplett
und dann hier ist auch wichtig dass ihr
diese Falten rein macht
[Musik]
und auch hier die messerrückseite könnt
ihr ganz gut benutzen
[Musik]
das ist mal das Grundgerüst und jetzt
brauche ich da noch etwas weiß für hier
vorne den also für den Saum ich hoffe
das heißt so und hier für den Baumarkt
Saum gut für den weißen Saum ich hoffe
das heißt so weiter Mütze da oben heißt
es Saum vielleicht könnt ihr mir das
Schreiben ihr wisst bestimmt besser
nehme ich einfach etwas weißen Fondant
oder gerne mischen mit CMC Pulver oder
auch Blütenpaste damit aushärtet aber
das muss jetzt nicht sein denn das ist
jetzt nichts wahnsinnig aufwendiges
dann muss doch ein größeres Stück sein
Roll ich das etwas dick aus und versucht
es zu strukturieren ich guck mal ob ich
das gleich mit einer Schere mache aber
dann fällt mir wieder dann die Flyer und
dann oh nee das kann ich halt nicht ich
muss es irgendwie anders strukturiert
bekommen vielleicht habe ich eine
strukturelle ich gucke gleich noch eine
strukturelle
ich sag's euch dieser ausroller dieser
Backform ausroller der ist gamechanger
im Fondant Spiel ja
der ist richtig gamechanger als ich lass
das so ein bisschen als dicke Rolle
also immer nicht ob es funktioniert so
wie ich mir das vorstelle aber meistens
schon also ich nehme jetzt die
strukturrolle ihr könnt aber auch ein
Stück Alufolie nehmen zerknüllen oder
zum Beispiel trockenen Reis in
Zewa also unsere Küchentuch rein und
dann wie so ein Kissen halten in etwas
unseren Gefrierbeutel wie so ein Kissen
halten und dann so drüber Stempeln und
da habt ihr eigentlich so den gleichen
Effekt wie hier also so ein bisschen
Struktur einfach auf die Oberfläche
bekommen etwas flach drücken
und dann hoffe ich
dass das gleich schön wird
naja also
doch cool aus oder
und dann ankleben aber das mache ich
jetzt daran denn dann kann ich den
Übergang so ein bisschen
Schleiern
das Gute an dieser Fondant Mitte ist man
kann sie noch so ein bisschen Formen
dein Kopf entsprechend
[Musik]
und immer wenn ich mir sicher bin dann
Astrid geklebt
die Übergänge am besten so ein bisschen
nach unten stopfen
und dann fehlt jetzt nur noch der Bommel
[Musik]
ihr wisst was jetzt kommt oder ihr wisst
eigentlich was jetzt kommt wir brauchen
einen Namen für mein Lebkuchenmännchen
oder Weibchen das dürft ihr entscheiden
also gebt bitte meinem lebkuchenmenschen
jetzt einen Namen schreibt den gerne in
die Kommentare und der süßeste Name der
wird dann ausgesucht
[Musik]
ich habe zwar jetzt noch keine Namen für
dich
aber ich würde sagen wir schneiden dich
jetzt an okay wenn ihr mich danach
wieder zusammensetzt
[Musik]
möchtest du Torte probieren
wie bitte möchtest du Torte probieren
komm mal hoch ich komme
aufgeräumt
[Applaus]
ja was haben wir denn hier schönes
it's beginning
like Christmas
everywhere you go
to my christmas cake
the Counts and chocolates plays inside
das ist echt cool aus oder ach komm der
ist richtig süß geworden wir haben noch
keine Namen aber die Community wird
einen Namen herausfinden und in die
Kommentare schreiben denn ich hatte
schon kalte Kürbis water watermelon wir
hatten ja echt schon einige gell wir
hatten echt einige bin ich mal gespannt
wie kreativ ihr seid ja schaffst du so
ein ganzes Bein
okay sein
es tut ein Baby schon Leid
der süße kleine wir haben uns irgendwie
so gerade angefreundet
ich muss das Messer sauber machen so ein
Tick von mir
wie lange hast du jetzt gebrauchen nur
einer denkt sich
wie lange ich dafür gebraucht habe ich
habe tatsächlich jetzt so eineinhalb
Tage immer mal wieder dran gearbeitet
ich lass dir den Vortritt das ist sehr
lieb ich finde es schon also echt süß
ich habe mir süß vorgestellt aber nicht
so
und richtig lecker ja
der war beim Schneiden ein bisschen
bröselig
das schmeckt echt nach Weihnachten
ich hatte Angst dass er trocken wird
mit dem Cranberries und der Creme
Marmelade rein Fruchtaufstrich
ich glaube ich habe auch
Fruchtaufstriche mein Engel fruchtiges
ist
gut
richtig lecker ach schön also dann ist
das meine diesjährige Weihnachtstorte
euch freue mich richtig dieses süß
geworden und ich hoffe der ein oder
andere von euch backt sie mal nach wenn
ja dann markiert uns gerne auf Social
Media dann reposten wir nämlich eure
Torten und vielleicht sehen ja eure
Lebkuchenmännchen oder Weibchen einfach
ganz anders aus ihr könnt ja wirklich
ihr könnt ja auch ein Kleidchen machen
oder dann
weihnachtskittel das kann man dann noch
so ein Mädchen draus machen oder eine
Krawatte kann man auch da oh eine
Krawatte ist auch süß oder einfach die
die Linien hier diese Zuckerschrift so
ein bisschen bunt und ausgestalten also
da gibt's wirklich alle möglichen alle
möglichen Ideen und ich wünsche euch
jetzt schon mal ein schönes
Weihnachtsfest
und wir genießen den Kuchen die Torte
jetzt mit dem Team ja die werden sich
alle freuen tschüss
[Musik]